THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURNER HORSEBACK
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY.
DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY GENE Là MON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS REYES THREE OF
US ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TEAM VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA EVER NISHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
YESTERDAY THE VERNAL EQUINOX
MARKED THE BEGINNING OF THE
SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WE ARE TRANSITIONING FROM THE
COLD OF WINTER TOWARDS THE HEAT
OF SUMMER.
BUT FOR NOW THE LONG WINTER
NIGHTS HAVE GROWN SHORTER UNTIL
AT THE EQUINOX THE DAYS AND
NIGHTS ARE OF EQUAL MING.
THE WEATHER IS NOT TOO HOT OR
TOO COLD.
NOT TOO WET OR TOO DRY.
WE SENSE NATURE IS THEN THE
MOMENT OF BALANCE AND HARMONY.
AS WE SEE THE RENEWING OF LIFE
IN THE MOUNTAINS AND VALLEYS
AROUND US.
EACH FLOWER WE SEE BLOOMING IS
MANIFESTING THE MIRACLE OF LIFE
RENEWING.
EVEN THE MOST INSIGNIFICANT
FLOWER IN BLOOM.
IS REALIZING ITS FULL POTENTIAL.
EACH FLOWER WE SEE BLOSSOMING IS
A REMINDER FOR US TO OPEN OUR
HEARTS TO FULLY EXPERIENCING THE
BEAUTY AND WONDER OF LIFE.
AS WE WELCOME THE SPRING SEASON.
LET US OPEN OUR WISDOM EYES AND
SEE.
ALL AROUND US.
THE MIRACLE OF LIFE RENEWING.
EVERY BLOSSOM REMINDING US TO
REALIZE OUR FULL POTENTIAL AS
TRUE HUMAN BEINGS.
NO MORE ME DOWN TO WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND ESTá WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REAVIS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE [inaudible]
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
[inaudible] TWO THREE ONE
NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON BILL
STEVEN CHOI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTY EIGHT DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK MISTER BONTA MOVES
IN MISTER DEEP SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE IS
THE BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
TODAY OUR ABSENCES ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALLED AROUND
COOPER AND GRAY FOR ILLNESS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE MOAN FOR
A DEATH IN THE FAMILY.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON TO HAVE
GUESTS.
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
HIS GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT HIS
DESK.
WITH OUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOLEY DOLLY.
GRAY LACKEY AND MAYES TO SPEAK
ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
TO RE REFER TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN PATTERSON FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN FRAZIER
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BLOOM
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AND AB FIFTEEN OH NINE MULLIN
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK. TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CONTACT.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY [inaudible]
MR GRAYSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY TODAY
ARE SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS.
THE MEMBERS OF THE VISTA DEL
LAGO HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS CROSS
COUNTRY TEAM.
ON NOVEMBER.
TWENTY FOUR THE TEAM WON THE
STATE CROSS COUNTRY
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
BESTING HOUSE THERE IS HIGH
SCHOOL BY A SCORE OF ONE TWENTY
FIVE TO ONE THIRTY THREE THIS
HISTORIC WIN WAS THE FIRST IN
SCHOOL HISTORY AND OUR COMMUNITY
IS SO PROUD OF THEIR HARD WORK.
AND COMMITMENT TO SUCCESS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING OUR
STATE CHAMPIONS AND WALKING THEM
TO THE STATE CAPITOL
.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY TO INTRODUCE --
ONE OF THE FAVORITE PEOPLE IN MY
LIFE -- MY
SISTER WHO HAS COME OUT FROM THE
MIDWEST TO BE WITH ME TODAY.
AND AN INTERESTING DYNAMIC ABOUT%
TO MY SISTER SHERRY IS THAT --
I HAVE ALSO ANOTHER SISTER NAMED
TAMMY.
MY OTHER SISTER TAMMY SHE
MARRIED A TIM ITEM MERRY TO
TAMMY AND BOTH MY WIFE AND I
HAVE SISTERS NAME SHERRY.
AND SO --
WITH THAT ONE OF THE SERIES CAME
OUT -- MY
CHERIE TODAY AND SHE IS OUT HERE
TO HELP ME --
CELEBRATE WORLD DOWN SYNDROME
AWARENESS DAY AS WELL AS TO
PROMOTE SPECIAL OLYMPICS THIS
WEEK.
AND FOR DOWN SYNDROME IN CASE
YOU DON'T KNOW PEOPLE IN THE ID
THE COMMUNITY.
THAT HAVE A FULL OR A PARTIAL
COPY OF THE CHROMOSOME TWENTY
ONE HENCE THREE TWENTY ONE SO
MARCH TWENTY FIRST BEING WORLD
DOWN SYNDROME DAY.
AND I HAVE --
A HERO IN MY LIFE --
HEROIN JUST --
SHERRY YOU'RE A GREAT SISTER AND
YOU -- TEACH
ME EVERY DAY OF WHAT LIFE IS
REALLY ALL ABOUT.
AND EVERYONE SO YOU GIVE ME A
HARD TIME BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
OLDER SISTERS ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND I WILL WE WELCOME YOU TODAY
AS WELL AS MY WIFE TAMMY ON THE
FLOOR WITH ME AND THEN MY OTHER
SISTER STEPHANIE AND DAVE MARTIN --
WHO BROUGHT SHERRY OUT TO BE
WITH ME THIS HELP WELCOME MY
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE?
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
AB FILE ITEMS NUMBER --
SECOND READING.
SOME PEOPLE TO TWENTY EIGHT WITH
THE MEMONS FIFTY FOUR TO A
216-918-9230 NINETEEN NINETY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN WITH THE
MOMENTS THREE FIFTY SIX FIVE
NINETY FIVE ONE FIFTY FOUR WITH
THE MINUTES THREE EIGHTY ONE
WITH THE MEMONS FIVE NINETY
SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT THREE
NINETY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT.
AND THIRTY FIVE WITH THE MOMENT.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEBT DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO FILES.
AND THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
WILL BE PASSED THE RETAINS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THREE TWENTY SEVEN
BY SOMETHING NUMBER MAIENSCHEIN
AND ACTUALLY TO STATES AND
TRUSTS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAY OPEN ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU MADAM.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE
TWENTY SEVEN MAKES A SIMPLE
CLARIFICATION AND LAW BY ADDING
A NEW SECTION OF PROBATE CODE.
THAT WILL ELIMINATE AND
AMBIGUITY CAUSED BY THE LENS
CASE THANK YOU KNOW I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
A. B..
THREE TWENTY SEVEN ALL MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE PLEASE VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RAW.
I SIXTY THREE NO [inaudible]
ZERO A FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN
WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AC
ARE ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
IMMIGRATION AND NATIONALITY ACT.
MR BONTA YOU MAY OPEN ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ACR ONE EXPRESSES
OPPOSITION TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSED CHANGES.
TO THE IMMIGRATION POLICY KNOWN
AS PUBLIC.
THAT TARGET ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CAUSE HARDSHIP TO
UNTOLD NUMBERS OF IMMIGRANTS
TRYING TO REALIZE THEIR OWN
AMERICAN DREAM.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS RUN
CONTRARY TO CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
INTO BIPARTISAN EFFORTS THAT.
HAVE RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
SUPPORTING AND WELCOMING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR STATE.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS WOULD
EXPAND THE LIST OF BENEFITS
CONSIDERED WHEN DETERMINING WHO
CONSTITUTES A PUBLIC CHARGE
BEYOND CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
TO INCLUDE HEALTHCARE HOUSING IN
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
PROGRAMS THAT HELP ALL PEOPLE
AND THEIR FAMILIES STAY HEALTHY.
WORK THRIVE AND CONTRIBUTE TO
SOCIETY.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS WOULD
ALSO CONSIDER THE AGE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BEEN UNDER EIGHTEEN
AND OVER SIXTY ONE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A NEGATIVE.
THE ABSENCE OF CURRENT
EMPLOYMENT OR LACK OF
PERSPECTIVE EMPLOYMENT THE USE
OF PUBLIC BENEFITS ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND INCOME
LEVEL SO QUITE LITERALLY IF
YOU'RE YOUNG OR IF YOU'RE OLD IF
YOU'RE SICK OR IF YOU'RE POOR.
IF YOU DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH IT
WILL ALL COUNT AGAINST YOU UNDER
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS.
THESE PROPOSED CHANGES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND LOW WAGE LABORERS
IN ADDITION OVER 70% OF THOSE
IMPACTED.
OUR CHILDREN.
THESE CHANGES I'VE BEEN DEEMED A
PUBLIC CHARGE AND CONSEQUENTLY
DENIED LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS OR ENTRY TO THE US OR
POTENTIALLY BEING SUBJECT TO
DEPORTATION FOR SEEKING.
ESSENTIAL BENEFITS CREATES
ADDITIONAL FEAR AND CHILLING
EFFECTS WITHINAND AMONG OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ACR ONE
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
RECONSIDER.
AND ROLL BACK THESE PROPOSED
CHANGES.
COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN
THE NATION BOTH DOCUMENTED AND
UNDOCUMENTED.
AND WE HAVE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA IS STRONGER WHEN
RESIDENTS IN NEED ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS IT SAFETY NET WITHOUT
FEAR FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILIES.
OR THEIR FUTURES.
COLLEAGUES AS THE AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND ON BEHALF OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON A C. R..
ONE MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ADVICE ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS --
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE A MOMENT ONLY TALK ABOUT
THE FACES THAT THIS BILL WOULD
AFFECT.
IT WOULD AFFECT MY FAMILY.
OUT THERE I SAID DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
AT SOME POINT BEEN ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
IMMIGRANT SUCH AS CAME HERE
WANTING TO BETTER THEIR LIFE AND
ENSURE THAT THEIR KIDS HAD A
BETTER LIKE TO SING THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM.
IMMIGRANT TO NOW PAY THEIR TAXES
AND ARE POSITIVE CONTRIBUTION TO
SOCIETY AND HAVE RAISED ME TO BE
THE LEADER THAT I AM HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY WOULDN'T BE
HERE WITH WILL'S LIKED IS AS THE
DAUGHTER OF A FATHER WHO STILL
SEEKING HIS CITIZENSHIP.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTIVE FAMILY MEMBER GARCIA.
AS THE DAUGHTER OF A FATHER WHO
STILL SEEKING TO BECOME A
CITIZEN WHO'S AFRAID TO TRAVEL
TO MEXICO BECAUSE HE'S AFRAID
THAT HE MIGHT BE DETAINED AT THE
AIRPORT EVEN THOUGH HE IS.
LEGAL RESIDENTS.
WHO DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH TO
THIS DATE --
BUT IS OUT THERE DOING SOME
GREAT WORK THIS IS THAT THESE
ARE THE FACES OF THE FACES HERE
IN OUR BODY THESE ARE THE FACES
BACK IN MY DISTRICT MY NEIGHBORS
ARE AFFECTED BY THESE POLICIES.
MY NEIGHBORS ARE AFRAID TO GO TO
THE DOCTOR MY NEIGHBORS ARE PAID
TO GO TO SCHOOL MY NEIGHBORS ARE
AFRAID TO DO THEIR DAILY
BUSINESS ON A REGULAR BASIS
BECAUSE OF POLICIES LIKE THIS.
SO I THINK AT SOME POINT EVERY
REMEMBER THE FACE THAT ARE OUT
THERE BUT THE FACES THAT AFFECTS
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
MEMBERS WITHIN OUR OWN BODY Là
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS.
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY THESE
POLICIES SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I BUILT ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY ON BEHALF OF MY NEIGHBORS?
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THOSE OUT
THERE WHO ARE IN FEAR EVERY DAY
BY THESE POLICIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
YES MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND AS A PROBLEM CO
AUTHOR OF A C. R..
ONE WE KNOW THAT OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVED ITSELF
TO BE THE POLAR OPPOSITE OF WHAT
WE STAND.
FOR WE STAND FOR JUSTICE WE
STAND FOR INCLUSION WE SANTA
EQUITY AND WE STAND FOR
OPPORTUNITY.
THE REGULATIONS PROPOSED OTHER
PART BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY RUN COUNTER TO
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES AND
BIPARTISAN EFFORTS AND RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE OF INTEGRATING
IMMIGRANTS POPULATIONS INTO THE
STATE.
THE LATEST MOVE IS AN ATTACK ON
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
THESE PROPOSED CHANGES TARGET
LOW INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANTS
AND BUT IT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOW
WAGE LABORERS.
THE PROPOSED BROADENING OF
BENEFITS CONSIDERED WHEN MAKING
QUOTE PUBLIC CHARGE
DETERMINATIONS THREATENS TO DO
NOT ELIGIBLE IMMIGRANTS
APPLICANTS A GREEN CARD IF THEY
ARE PERSON BELOW A CERTAIN
INCOME LEVEL.
OR ACCESS CRITICAL HEALTHCARE
NUTRITION OR OTHER FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM.
THESE CHANGES HAVE REAL IMPACT
THE FEAR OF BEING DEEMED A
PUBLIC CHARGE AND DID NOT LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS OR INTO TO
THE U. S. OR POTENTIALLY BEING
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION FOR
SEEKING CENTRAL BENEFITS.
CREATES ADDITIONAL FEAR AMONG
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES GEN
LEARNING A PARENTS WORKING AND
FAMILY STRONG.
ACR ONE CONDEMNS A PROPOSED
CHANGES AND URGES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RECONSIDER AND
ROLL BACK THESE CHANGES WHICH
WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY HARM THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC WELL BEING
OF THE STATE AND THE NATION FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE BAY AREA FOR BRING A
SEE I WANT TO THE FLOOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER DOCTOR
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
A SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS SAW I
A NEED TO MAKE A POINT OF ORDER --
ON THE S. R. A C. R..
ACR CLEARLY URGES STEVE FAT
ORDER.
GOVERNMENT THE TO ROLL BACK I IS
THE IMMIGRATION POLICY.
OUR LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE'S TO
RULE ORDER REQUIRES SO.
ASSEMBLY TO ASSIGN THE ART
RESOLUTION --
TO BE NAMED DOT A. B. J. ARE NOT
AS HE ARE --
ON THE FEATHER IN MATTERS.
HOW DO I A NOISE?
MY A. R. AJ ARE ALL.
SIX OUR WHICH WAS ON A
RESOLUTION ON THE KOREAN MARCH
MOVEMENT.
TO A COULDN'T BE INTRODUCED ON
ON THE SCHEDULED DATE OF OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH.
JUST BECAUSE OVER THIS REASON --
SOMEHOW LEGISLATURE'S CELL
COUNSELOR GAVE US SAW.
A J. R. WHICH WAS NOT FEDERAL
MATTER AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
C. R..
EVEN SO I HAD THE OUT OF TOWN
GUESTS --
VISITING INCLUDING DIGNITARIES
SO.
I COULD NOT THE TAKE A AND THE
WHAT IS --
WHAT IS SAW --
DESPITE IS SO RULES --
THIS IS A CLEARLY FEATHER MATTER.
AW BUT THOUGH YOU ARE TRYING.
TO A PASS THIS ONE WITH THE AC
ARE IT SHOULD BE A CONSISTENT.
AND THE FAIR TO ALL MEMBERS OF
WITH THE REGULATIONS.
SO THEREFORE.
I ASK YOU TO NOT TO TAKE UP THIS
MATTER TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
YOUR OWN REGULATIONS UNTIL THIS
MATTER IS CORRECTED.
DOCTOR CHOI ARE YOU RAISING A
POINT OF ORDER ON THIS.
RESOLUTION.
OKAY WELL THE RESOLUTION WAS
DRAFTED IN CONSULTATION WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE FORWARD.
MR GIVES IN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AC ONE I THANK THE
AUTHOR FROM OAKLAND.
BRING IN THIS MEASURE.
FOR WE S. A STATE.
AND AS A COUNTRY HAVE A MORAL
AND CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
EVERY. TO TO EVERYONE OF OUR
RESIDENTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO DELIVER
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SERVICE AND
BENEFITS THAT PROMOTES THEIR
HEALTH AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE.
PUBLIC CHARGE WOULD LEAD TO A
LARGE DECREASE IN PARTICIPATION
IN HEALTH CARE SERVICES AMONG
LEGAL IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
INCLUDING SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS INFANTS AND
CHILDREN.
THE PUBLIC CHARGE RULE WOULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT REAL FAMILIES
IN A VERY REAL WAY.
WE IS CALIFORNIANS AND AS
AMERICANS SHOULD STAND TOGETHER
AND PROTECTS ALL FAMILIES LIVING
HERE.
AND CONDEMN THE FEDERAL A PUBLIC
CHARGE AMERICA WE'RE BETTER THAN
THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT AYE
VOTE OR ACR.
ONE THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER MISTER MONTE MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
INPUT AND FOR YOUR DEBATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON A C. R..
ONE YES I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE FIRST
ROLE FOR COOPERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRED TO BE CO
AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THEIR FIFTY THREE CO AUTHORS AND
NOW WILL MOVE TO A VOICE VOTE
ALL IN FAVOR.
OF A C. R. WINDS SAY I ALL
OPPOSED.
IS RESOLUTION PASSES.
MOVING ON CHIU FILE ITEM UNDER
TWENTY ONE HR.
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY RELATIVE
TO NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK.
MR COOLEY MAY OPEN ON THIS
MATTER.
COLLEAGUES I'M DELIGHTED TODAY
2% HOUSE RESOLUTION. NINETEEN TO
DESIGNATE THE WEEK OF MARCH
SEVENTEENTH THIS WEEK THROUGH
MARCH TWENTY THIRD IS NATIONAL
SURVEYORS WEEK [inaudible]
AND AS A PART OF THIS.
CERVANTES NATURE PROFESSION AND
PERMISSION TO READ.
YES PERMISSION GRANTED
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
ON A SOLITARY MONUMENT.
IN SOUTHWEST PENNSYLVANIA.
ARE FOUND THE FOLLOWING WORDS.
MADE FAMOUS AS THE LINE BETWEEN
FREE AND SLAVE STATES BUT BEFORE
THE WAR BETWEEN THE STATES.
THE SURVEY ESTABLISH IN MARYLAND
PENNSYLVANIA BOUNDARY BEGAN IN.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE HALTED BY
INDIAN WARS AND SEVENTY SIX TO
SEVEN AND CONTINUED TO SOUTHWEST
CORNER I TENDED.
TO MARK.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE MASON
DIXON LINE.
WAS A LINE SURVEYED OVER EIGHTY
MILES TO VIRGIN FOREST.
THE ACCOUNT OF HOW THEY SURVEYED
THAT LINE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
HOW YOU WOULD.
POSSIBLY SURVEY ALIGNED TO
TIMBER.
THE SURVEYORS WERE ACCOMPANIED
BY WOOD CUTTERS TO CUT DOWN
TREES.
THEY SET UP MONUMENTS WITH
CANDLES.
SO THEY DECIDE OVER LONG
DISTANCES BY NIGHT USING THE
AVAILABLE TOOLS.
THAT LINE SETTLED AN EIGHTY YEAR
OLD DISPUTE.
AND PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN EARLY
AMERICAN TO THIS BOUNDARY OF
NORTH AND SOUTH.
THE PRACTICE OF SURVEYING
[inaudible]
SETTLES DISPUTES.
IT GAVE RISE TO AN INDUSTRY THE
TITLE INSURANCE INDUSTRY IS AS
ACCURATELY DETERMINED BOUNDARIES.
SUPPORT OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM OF
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND INDEED THOSE TITLES ARE
RELIED UPON AND SUBJECT --
TO INSURANCE.
THE RECORDING SYSTEM AND ALL OF
OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AS
ACROSS THE NATION RELIES UPON.
WELL DEFINED BOUNDARIES AND
SURVEYS AND RECORDS.
HEARING SACRAMENTO WE HAVE OUR
OWN ARTIFACT. TO THE HISTORY OF
SURVEYING.
WHEN JOHNSON REQUIRED HIS LAND
FROM THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO?
STRETCHING OUT TO ALEC HAMBRO
WHAT WE THINK VALVES ON HAMMER
THE RIVER.
IN OLD SACRAMENTO.
HE SAID SURVEYING TEAMS TO WORK
TO LAY OUT THE GRID OF DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO.
HIS SURVEYING TEAMS WERE
ASSIGNED TO CREATE BLOCKS OF A
SPECIFIED SIZE.
AND THOSE TWO TEAMS MET.
ON THE EDGES OF THE BLOCK
BETWEEN TWELFTH AND THIRTEENTH.
SO ACCORDING TO JACK SHELBY
WHOSE DAUGHTER WORKS FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY A FORMER CITY
COUNCILMAN HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THAT BLOCK IS LARGER THAN ALLTHE OTHER BLOCKS IN THE DOWNTOWN.
WHICH IS WHY YOU SEE THE HIGH
THE SHERATON THE BLOCK BETWEEN
TWELFTH AND THIRTEENTH.
AND IN MY OWN DISTRICT THE EIGHT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HAVE YOU EVER
DRIVE DOWN SOUTH ON A CLEAR DAY
ON GRANT LINE.
OUT IN SOUTHEAST COUNTY BUT HEAD
OF THE SOUTHWEST.
YOU REALIZE THAT GRANT LINE ROAD.
ALIGNS WITH DISTANT MOUNT
DIAMBIL.
WHICH SERVED AS THE BASIS OF
SURVEYS ALL OVER NORTH STATE WAS
ESTABLISHED.
SO COLLEAGUES I'M VERY PLEASED
TO PRESENT.
HR NINETY ONE SURVEY HAS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE CENTRAL PART OF
OUR CITIES SINCE THE BEGINNING
RECORDED HISTORY.
REQUIRED IN PLANNING USE IT
EVERY FORMER CONSTRUCTION.
IT REMAINS ESSENTIAL TO
CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS FIELDS
OF TRANSPORTATION COMMUNICATIONS
MAPPING LEGAL BOUNDARIES.
SURVEYORS USE A GREAT MANY
SKILLS ON TOP OF THEIR INGENUITY.
BUT ELEMENTS OF MATHEMATICS
PHYSICS ENGINEERING LONG HISTORY.
AND NOTABLE SURVEYORS INCLUDE
GEORGE WASHINGTON THOMAS
JEFFERSON ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
OTHER LEWIS AND HIS COLLEAGUE
WILLIAM CLARK FROM THAT GREAT
EXPEDITION.
DANIEL BOONE HENRY THOREAU AND
OF COURSE CHARLES MASON AND
JEREMIH DIXON.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZE
YOU SENT TO WORK IN OUR
CALIFORNIA SERVERS DO.
IT DOESN'T MAKE THIS WEEK IS
NATIONAL SERVERS WEEK.
NEXT RECORD ASSN THE ROLE BE
OPEN INITIALLY FOR COAL AUTHORS
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER THE
FIRST ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON HR.
NINETEEN THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
ITS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE WRONG.
THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
ON HR NINETEEN AND MOVED TO A
VOICE VOTE ALL IN FAVOR OF HR
NINETEEN SAY I ALL OPPOSED.
THIS RESOLUTION PASSES.
MOVING ON I AM FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO THREE TWENTY FIVE OR
PASSED THE ROUTINES.
MISTER WHO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
VERY GOOD I AM DELIGHTED
INTRODUCED A NUMBER OF GUESTS IN
THE ROOM THANK YOU FOR STANDING.
AND HAVE ORDER PRESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAN SERVERS
ASSOCIATION.
CAMERINO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAND SERVERS SO
SHE ASIAN.
WHICH TO WRECK MORE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS.
AND STEVE WILSON PRESENT THE
MONTEREY BAY NATIVE SACRAMENTO
WHO BEGAN HER CAREER THE PART
TRANSPORTATION.
SHE BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN IN
HER DIFFERENT TO PASS A LAND
SURVEYOR IN TRAINING EXAM.
AND BECAME ASSISTANT LAND
SURVEYOR SHE CURRENTLY IS A
SENIOR LAND SURVEYOR IN CHARGE
OF DATA MANAGEMENT IN SACRAMENTO.
WITH CALTRANS.
KIM IS WORK FOR CALIFORNIA
DISPENSERS SERVICES TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WAS THIS FROM THE PLAN AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF NUMEROUS
SEMINARS CONFERENCES AND TRADE
SHOWS IN HER FIELD.
RICK IS A VETERAN LAND SURVEYOR
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HE WAS
CONTRACTED AS THE LAN SERVER
CONSULTANT. TO THE BOARD FOR
PROFESSIONAL INJURES LAN SERVERS
AND GEOLOGISTS.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN APPOINTED AS
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
SHE WAS BEEN A PROFESSIONAL LAND
SURVEYOR IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO FIRST
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN TO
THE BOARD OF REGISTRATION FOR
ENGINEERS A LAN SERVERS.
HE SERVED THERE FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THEIR VISION TODAY
JUST CELEBRATE.
NATIONAL LAND SURVEYORS WEAK AND
BRING AWARENESS OF THIS
ESSENTIAL FUNCTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU
HERE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NOW MOVING TO THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
THIRTY THROUGH.
THIRTY FIVE THE RESOLUTION THERE
ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR SO BEFORE WE
VOTE WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE TO ALLOW ALL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AS CO AUTHORED
THE RESOLUTIONS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER RAY
IS RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S MILITARY
HISTORY WEEK.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER CHAD ON IS A
COOPER TO THIS RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLL CALL IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE IS SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR
BY SOME THE NUMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN PARTY [inaudible]
THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE [inaudible]
I SEVEN GUIDE ME.
I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
MAKE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN.
FORTY EIGHT I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO IS ON THE CURRENT VERSION.
EIGHT I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NINE ZERO
SIXTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR ADDITIONAL MOTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE. FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
TO NOTICE AB ONE THIRTY FOUR
BLOOM FOR A HEARING ON TUESDAY
MARCH TWENTY SIX PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOMEZ
RANTS N ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
ARE RUNNING THE LA MARATHON THIS
WEEKEND WE WISH THEM THE BEST OF
LUCK.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND.
NO FLOOR SESSION AND NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MARCH TWENTY
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM
.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAHLE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN.
MEMORY OF ROBERT GAINES IT
SENATOR GAINES IS --
FATHER ROBERT GAINES WAS A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE WHO STOOD FOR
CORE VALUES.
OF OUR STATE HE GREW UP IN
BERKELEY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN
HE JOINED THE ARMY AIR CORPS.
SERVING AS A TAIL GUNNER ON A B.
SEVENTEEN IN WORLD WAR.
TWO AFTER SERVING HIS COUNTRY HE
ENROLLED AT USED UC BERKELEY
WHERE HE MET HIS WIFE WENT FOR
IT.
WITH WHOM HE HAD SIX CHILDREN.
IT ABOUT CHRISTIAN.
ROBERT BECAME DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
THE TRINITY CATHEDRAL IT IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE HE TAUGHT
SUNDAY SCHOOL.
PARTICIPATED IN CHURCH VESTRY
AND PROVIDED MINISTRY TO THE
SICK AND HOME BOUND.
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT HUSBAND FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER AND WE KNOW HE
KNEW HE WE KNOW HE NOW IS JOINED
WITH HIS WIFE IN HAVE AND?
LEAVE BEHIND A LEGACY OF SERVICE
TO OUR COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY.
I ASK MEMBERS THAT WE JOIN IN
THE GERMAN MEMORY OF ROBERT
GAINES.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI.
MR KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS THE GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO REMEMBER THE
LIFE OF ROBERT GAINES WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT THE AGE
OF NINETY THREE ROBERT WAS A
NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA WHO LOVED
HIS STATE.
AND HIS COUNTRY.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN ROBERT
ENLISTED IN THE ARMY AIR CORPS.
ULTIMATELY THROUGH THE FLU
THIRTY FIVE MISSIONS OVER
GERMANY.
IN WORLD WAR.
TWO HIS LOVE OF COUNTRY WAS ONLY
SURPASSED BY HIS LOVE. FOR HIS
FAMILY.
HE HIS WIFE MET UC BERKELEY IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX THEY WERE
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
AND IT SIX CHILDREN TOGETHER.
ONE OF WHOM I TED GAINES OF
COURSE WAS A MEMBER OF THIS BODY
A STATE SENATOR AND NOW SITS ON
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
ROBERT WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY
HIS SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FOREVER REMEMBERED FOR HIS
COMMITMENT AND DEVOTION TO GOD.
HIS FAMILY AND HIS NATION.
MADAM SPEAKER I ASK THE TODAY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
ROBERT GAINES.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY MISTER
COOLEY WERE ALSO RECOGNIZED ON
THE SITUATION IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I ALSO JUST WANT A
RISE IN HONOR OF MISTER GAINES.
OF COURSE SHE HAD OF A A SON WHO
SERVED IN THIS BODY WENT ON TO
SERVE IN THE SENATE.
HIS DAUGHTER LOS SERVED IN THIS
BODY.
IS BEEN DESCRIBED HOW HE SERVED
HIS COUNTRY IN THE ARMY AIR
CORPS WHICH MY FATHER ALSO
SERVED IN.
I KNOW FROM MY DAD --
THAT THAT WAS A SOLEMN
RESPONSIBILITY FILLED WITH.
TIMES OF BOARDING TIMES OF GREAT
ANXIETY --
IS BEEN DESCRIBED HOW HE CAME
BACK WENT TO SCHOOL ESTABLISHED
A BUSINESS.
WHICH HE MADE A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS SUCH THAT HE'S PASSED
IT ON TO HIS KIDS [inaudible]
OUR BUT A MAN WHO EXHIBITED SUCH.
STEADFASTNESS IN DUTY ENTERPRISE
IN BUSINESS.
OUR TOUCH ALLIES OF HIS KIDS
SUCH THAT THEY'VE GONE ON TO
PUBLIC SERVICE [inaudible]
OBVIOUSLY.
MR GAINES WAS INFLUENTIAL FOR
THOSE WHO DO FOR THOSE HE
TOUCHED AS HE GREW UP.
AND WE HAVE BEEN THE
BENEFICIARIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FROM THE SPIRIT OF SERVICE THAT
HE ENGENDERED IN.
IN HIS CHILDREN AND HIS DAUGHTER
IN LAW -- SO
I JUST ASKED WE HONOR HIM.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS BODY THIS DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER KAREEM.
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THE MEDICINE BAKER THAN --
MEMBERS.
I ASKED WE JOIN TODAY IN MEMORY
OF PAUL WOODRUFF A FORMER MEMBER
OF THIS BODY WHO PASSED AWAY
LAST WEEK AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
FIFTY NINE PAUL STARTED HIS
POLITICAL CAREER AS A STAFFER
FOR THEN AS SOMEONE BILL LEONARD.
AND WHEN I WENT ON TO SERVE
REPRESENTS AMBER YOU KNOW AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES IN THIS
CHAMBER FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR HE WAS A
KIND HEARTED CONSERVATIVE WHO
WAS AN EARLY ADVOCATE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AFTER LEAVING THE LEGISLATURE
POLITICS VERY SUCCESSFUL CAREER
IN THE MUSIC INDUSTRY.
HE RETIRED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
LEFT TO HELP CARE FOR HIS FATHER.
THOSE WHO KNEW PAUL WOULD TELL
YOU THAT HE WAS A GENTLEMAN HAD
A KEEN POLITICAL MIND IT WAS A
PASSED IN WAS PASSION ABOUT THE
HISTORY.
AND BEAUTY OF RULES SAN BENITO
COUNTY HE WE MISSED THANK
MINUTES BIGGER.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES MISTER
COOLEY WRECKER RECOGNIZED HER
OTHER GERMAN IN MEMORY.
COLLEGE TODAY I RISE TO JOURNEY
MEMORY OF DAVID LETTER BE SENIOR.
THE CO FOUNDER OF THE WELL KNOWN
SACRAMENTO.
OF LEATHER BEADS FAMILY CREAMERY.
IT IS JUST ONE OF MINE WHO
PASSED AWAY ON AGE OF EIGHTY ONE
MISTER LEVY WAS BORN APRIL
TWENTY NINTH NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IN HEDRICK IA. TO ALBERT
LEATHER B. AND BEVERLY OR FOR
YOUNG.
HE'S BEEN IS USED HELPING HIS
PARENTS RUN THEIR MAIN STREET
CAFE.
AND I MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
SALLY IN THE SIXTH GRADE.
AND THEY MARRIED IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE HE WENT TO
SCHOOL AT IOWA WESLEYAN COLLEGE
WAS A GIFTED ATHLETE ATHLETE
INVITED TO TRY OUT FOR THE GREEN
BAY PACKERS.
BUT LOOK AT IT IS FAMILY
CIRCUMSTANCE TO CLIMB THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
HE MOVED HOWEVER TO SACRAMENTO
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY HAD A JOB WAS
SAFE WAY.
AND AFTER THE ARRIVAL OF HIS
TENTH CHILD.
THEY WONDER COULD TO DRUG TO THE
COMMITTEE AND HE CREATE A
COMMUNITY GATHERING PLACE.
HE AND HIS SON DAVE JUNIOR OPEN
OTHER BEES FAMILY CREAM IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND THERE'S
BEEN A BEEN A STAPLE FOR DECADES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WITH LOCATION
IN ARDEN CITRUS HEIGHTS.
AND EVENTUALLY ELK GROVE --
IT WAS A MAN GUIDED BY HIS FAITH
INTEGRITY AND GENEROSITY
THROUGHOUT HIS WHOLE LIFE.
HE HAD CONVERTED TO CATHOLICISM
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND WAS
EARNESTLY DEVOUT FROM THAT TIME
ON REGULAR TEN AMASSED EACH
MORNING.
AND WHEN ASKED WHAT MADE IT SO
JOYFUL COULD RESPOND BY RAISING
HIS ROSARY --
DAVID LEATHER BE SENIORS
KINDNESS GENEROSITY WILL SURELY
BE MISSED.
MOST OF FRESH VICE FAMILY HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE. NINE IT
WAS TEN CHILDREN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN.
THERE STRICTLY AS WE JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF DAVID LED TO BE
SEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MR
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO JOURNAL MEMORY OF
OFFICER JONATHAN P. TENER.
OSCAR TENER PASSED AWAY ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
EIGHT AFTER.
HIS COURAGEOUS BATTLE WITH
CANCER.
IT WAS ONLY RECENTLY WHEN
OFFICER TENER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
AN INOPERABLE TURNER TUMOR.
ON A SPINAL CORD WHICH LIMITED
ALL MOVEMENT OF SENSATION IN HIS
LEGS.
A RESTRICTED MOBILITY IN HIS
UPPER BODY AND ARMS.
AS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY JONATHAN WANTED
TO GIVE BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY.
A DEDICATED LIFE TO PROTECTING
THE SAFETY A LIVELIHOOD OF HIS.
COMMUNITY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN JONATHAN
ROLLED IN THE SIEGE BE ACADEMY.
AND LATER THAT YEAR UPON
GRADUATING HIS DREAM CAME TRUE
AS IT WAS ASSIGNED TO PATROL THE
AREA THE RAISED HIM.
OFFICER JENNER HAD A BRIGHT
CAREER AHEAD OF THEM.
HE WAS HIGHLY RESPECTED WAS HELD
WITH THE UTMOST ESTEEM BY HIS
PEERS AT THE OTTAWA VALLEY CHP.
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
OFFICER TURNER WAS A LOVING
HUSBAND.
AND A CARING FATHER OF TWO BOYS.
IN HIS WIFE JUST SEE ARE ALSO
EXPECTING THEIR FIRST DAUGHTER
LATER THIS YEAR.
HE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS
PARENTS JAMIE AND DOLLY HIS TWO
OLDER BROTHERS HIS YOUNGER
SISTER.
AND HIS MOTHER AND FATHER IN LAW.
MEMBERS I SINCERELY ASK DO YOU
JOIN ME ON A JOURNEY.
AND ALSO JONATHAN TAYLOR'S
MEMORY.
TODAY AND PASSING ALONG YOUR
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER WRITINGS FROM ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED ALMOST AND SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS BOERNER HORVATH MOVES IN
MISTER LACKEY SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH TWENTY FIFTH AT ONE
PM